Ernest Becker has a great line he says
psychosis is just neurosis pushed to its
extreme and when you think about it we
spend so much of our lives
stuck in the monkey mind those
cul-de-sacs and error messages the
excessive rumination and
self-consciousness that keeps us trapped
in our own head that crippling
self-doubt that insecurity that
unwillingness to be endure now one of
the things I've always loved about
highly creative people extremely
extroverted characters that seem to come
alive like in an active improvisational
theater
with the way they live their lives how
can we bring more of that into our lives
how can we create gregarious
environments that allow us to move
beyond ourselves to exceed ourselves
instead of separated and isolated from
everybody else to feel so at ease to
feel so safe to feel so at home you can
tap into that true voice that true self
to be truly free that fear of judgment
so how do we get there how do we achieve
that how do we catapult into these kinds
of reveries well one way is
improvisational theater or another way
is probably music jam bands another way
is just simply participate in instances
of deep playing like when you're a child
Diane Ackerman has written about that
you know jump into the water shake
around and splash around with your
friends I find that you'll find it
healed
you